- What do you miss from the nineties?
I miss the music, I love
- Music, oh.
- I love nineties music.
- So do I, nineties music.
It's funny because early nineties,
it started off kind of grungy.
Then went a lot of cool R&B
then country remember was really big.
- [Kelly] I know. There's so much!
- I use to go line dancing all the time.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, me too!
- In Cahoots.
The nineties were big.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Garth Brooks and all that.
Right?
- Yes!
- And you know what I
really miss, to be honest,
I miss like having
conversations like this,
cuz it was pre social media.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Pre
Everyone with a smart phone
- It was like beeper world.
- Yes!
- If you were rich.
- [Mario] Yeah.
- I didn't have a beeper.
- [Mario] Well see everybody
that I knew had a beeper.
- Yeah because you were rich
- They were either like,
drug dealers or doctors,
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh, I didn't have one!
- [Kelly] Oh, I'm like, (laughs)
- They were either drug
dealers or doctors.
Those were the people I
knew that had beepers.
But I didn't have one.
- That's amazing.
- But, yeah, just the talking
and just the social aspects
and the music, like you said,
was great too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So it was fun.
- Oh my God I love the music.
- [Mario] I don't miss that hair.
that was atrocious.
(audience laughs)
- Dude, that's the greatest mullet ever.
Eat that, Blake Shelton!
(Mario laughs)
That mullet is awesome!
You wish!
All right, so if you had
to choose, in real life,
AC Slater or Zach Morris.
This is no lie.
My friends from childhood will say
I was all about the wrestler, y'all.
I was about some AC Slater.
- That's what's up.
- And it was so weird
cause my name is Kelly,
and they were like, "No,
you're Kelly Kapowski"
I was like, mm-mm I like AC Slater.
- [Mario] Ahh.
- I was like, I was...
I loved you.
- Aw, you're so sweet.
- [Kelly] So would you
relate to that character
more than Zach's?
- Yeah, you know what's funny?
First, my wife told me
that she would totally,
she grew up loving Zach,
so how ironic that she.
- Oh my God.
- I know. So funny.
- That's amazing, the honesty!
- It's so funny!
It's funny because he wasn't
supposed to be an athlete.
He wasn't supposed to play the drums.
He wasn't supposed to dance, any of that.
That was all stuff I did in real life.
- Oh, so it's really, yeah.
- So they,
It's more kind of me.
So they incorporated
that into my character.
He was supposed to be more
like a Vinnie Barbarino.
Like in Welcome Back,
Kotter, like kind of just
- Oh my gosh!
- like a street kid
- So all that other stuff and activities
that he did was me in real life.
And they just sort of incorporated that.
So I'm really more like him.
- Oh my God. Well he is you.
(Mario chuckles)
You're not him. He is you.
- [Mario] We're one the same (laughs).
- [Kelly] Yes. We are the same.
So okay, well let's do
some less controversial
nineties matchup.
- Okay.
- [Kelly] Would you pick
N'Sync or Backstreet Boys?
- Backstreet Boys had
had some good, slow jams,
but N'Sync had some jams
and made you want to move.
And so I was a little
bit more about N'Sync.
- I'm going to be honest with you,
I wasn't super into
boy bands but I do know
that N'Sync had this song
called I think it was
♪ Gone ♪
And it was really, really good.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(Kelly vocalizes)
Yeah, I liked their little R&B flavor.
- [Mario] And the whole
"Bye, Bye, Bye" thing,
that was great too.
- Yeah. Oh, the puppet thing?
- Yeah. No strings attached.
- Yeah. I didn't have MTV.
I saw that at some friend's house.
I was like, that's funny.
(Mario laughs)
Then I was like and kinda sad.
Cause are you puppets?
- Right, right, right.
- And I was like, I don't know, so.
Yeah, I was like, are
you okay, blink twice.
(audience laughs)
Okay, so "The Boy is Mine",
good song.
- [Mario] Great song.
- Or "Say My Name?" (gasps) I know mine.
- Ooh, that's a great song. You know what?
I love "The Boy is Mine."
(Kelly gasps)
- I'm going to have to go...
- ♪ Say my name, say my name ♪
- That's a great song too!
- ♪ When no one is around ♪
- That was great! That was great!
Destiny's Child. I love that song too.
But, "The Boy is Mine"
with Monica and Brandy,
I don't know, I used to
pretend I was the boy.
(Kelly screams)
(Both laugh)
- There was drama.
- In my mind, exactly.
They're both awesome though.
- They're both awesome songs.
They're both huge, successful songs.
But wait, okay, this
one's actually hard for me
because I love both. Friends or Seinfeld?
- [Mario] Seinfeld.
- [Kelly] Oh my God. You were so quick.
- I'm going with Seinfeld,
because I love Curb Your
Enthusiasm and I love...
- [Kelly] Oh my God, it's such
great humor. I love it too!
- Yeah.
- But I don't know, man.
Friends was so good too.
That's a hard one.
- Yeah. There's another, you know,
like picking between kids.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
Well how about the
Macarena or the Carlton?
- They both kind of still exist, right?
- One is cooler.
- Right, well, the Carlton.
- Yeah, one is cooler.
- For sure, for sure.
The Macarena they still do,
the Carlton, the Carltons go.
- The Macarena they still be doing.
I did it like at a
daddy/daughter dance I think.
- [Kelly] Aw! That's sweet.
- One of those.
You're one of those dads.
- [Mario] Yeah.